hi everyone welcome to the 2020 castle
lectures as many of you know the castle
lectures are the signature event of the
ethics politics and economics major and
we are so fortunate to have a very
distinguished speaker with us in who I
will introduce in just a minute but I
want to make sure everybody knows what
the castle lectures are so that you will
know what justice Cuellar is
contributing to what tradition he's
contributing to in 1988 john castle
provided money to yale that established
this lecture series to promote a concern
about ethical issues and particularly
ethical issues facing public policy in
society today and he did so in honor of
his ancestor Reverend James Pierpont how
many of you know who Reverend James
Pierpont is some of you some what he was
a harvard-trained Congregational
minister who founded the Collegiate
School of Connecticut in 1701 how many
of you know what the Collegiate School
of Connecticut is some of you do know it
was renamed after its benefactor Elihu
Yale and so he was one of the founders
of this institution and James Pierpont
son-in-law was Jonathan Edwards another
descendant was James Pierpont Morgan so
we are grateful to this family for their
contribution to Yale and to the ethics
politics and economics major and so
today tomorrow and Thursday
we are the beneficiaries of the wisdom
of justice mariano Florentino Cuellar
who is one of the key spokespeople and
thinkers and actors of our day around
issues that come before him in
California Supreme Court and these are
issues some of which you'll be talking
about today such as global warming the
role of money in society immigration and
you will all have a chance to
participate in the conversation so I'm
gonna suggest that we allow justice
Cuellar to have a have the floor we will
give students the first crack at
comments and questions from the floor
and we have until 5:30 for our
conversation but let me tell you a
little more about justice Cuellar this
is the second time that I've had the
honor to introduce him to an audience
the first time was several years ago
when he was inducted into the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences and at that
time I was I was very interested to
learn some things that I think you will
be interested to know as well in his
early teens he was living in Mexico and
he would daily cross the border from his
home in Matamoros Mexico to pursue a
junior high school education in
Brownsville Texas and in that daily
commute he learned a great deal about
his community and about the the broader
world the world he now says is as messy
and complicated as it is beautiful and
full of possibility and I think this
really does capture in some ways the
generosity of spirit that he has has
cultivated and brought with him to our
conversation today in 1993 he earned his
BA from Harvard he then got a JD from
Yale Law School after that he got a PhD
in political science at Stanford and
then he worked in the Clinton
administration he clerked for Chief
Judge Mary Schroder of the US Court of
Appeals for the Ninth Circuit before
accepting a position on the faculty of
the Stanford Law School where he still
works
still teaches while being a justice on
the Supreme Court of the state of
California in 2014 he was nominated by
then California Governor Jerry Brown to
the California Supreme Court and is now
the first Mexican born judge to serve on
that Court
where on behalf of the people of the
state he now applies the lessons that he
learned straddling political
disciplinary and professional boundaries
and so we're so fortunate to have this
very broadly educated and widely
absorbing of all of the worlds lessons
to share with us today so join me Thank
You professor Rosenbluth I will go
anywhere you want me to go to if you
introduce me thank you all of you for
being here I'm really grateful you know
it's such a huge honor to be back at
Yale in this capacity and I'll share a
little bit about why but I also want to
tell you my son who was annoyed that I
was taking this trip he said why are you
doing this only 5.75 people are gonna
show up I don't know where he came up
with 0.75 but I I will proudly tell him
that he has underestimated how many
people have have come so Yael and New
Haven has probably had a big effect on
all of you it's had a huge effect on me
I'll tell you a little bit about why I
remember being awed when I got here by
the vast breadth of knowledge and
insight and people by the incredible
architecture but also by the proximity
of yield to the city and by the
incredible contrast by the mix of
stunning beauty and architecture but
also how close it was to penury and
poverty this is only the sixth time I've
been back to New Haven since I graduated
from Law School in 1997 in one of those
times I came back and I came across
young Langbein who was one of Nick
Parrilla colleagues and Steve whismur's
colleagues a remarkable man who was a
sort of legendary teacher of the common
law and I said in Professor Langbein
I've never had I never had a chance to
take a class with you when I was here
and
whose fault was that so I that comes to
mind too and thinking why haven't I been
back to New Haven more it's my fault but
I hope to change that and I never
imagined that I'd have an honor like
this when I was in law school it's
brought back a flood of memories that I
was just jotting down earlier today as I
was thinking about how to start these
tucks I remember being in a class with
my torts professor peter shuck and what
it felt like when he called on me the
third or fourth day of torts class and
it turned out to be a very easy question
but he made this big fat check mark on
the on the chart after calling on me and
I just felt this rush of relief
I remember the thrill of being in Jeremy
Shaw's Administrative Law class and
making a comment and then hearing the
professor say yeah I agree with you I
think that's a very thoughtful way of
putting it and that warm glow kind of
stayed with me for days afterwards I
remember the joys and frustrations of
the immigration clinic as we worked on
asylum cases for African and Haitian
immigrants one of whom showed up on the
wrong day at least I maybe I had the
wrong day and I didn't know what to say
I remember also my younger brother who
was in high school at Wilbur cross and
living with me for you know a number of
reasons and it was just an unbelievable
experience to be sharing my time at Yale
with a kid who was in high school there
were some moments that were trying I was
at a seminar once a health policy
seminar and we had these pagers so we
would use back then back so you know
many of you don't didn't live through
that era but these paid these things
called pagers we didn't have cell phones
and so somebody called you on the pager
it would show a number and the code we
had was that if it was a real emergency
my brother would call the pager and it
would say 911 seven nine one one I left
my class went to this thing called a
payphone put a coin in it called my
brother and he said hey what are we
having for dinner and I said well I
don't know we have something at home and
he said okay we have peanut butter pasta
two eggs a pickle bread and an apple and
I could see both the possibilities and
the limitations of any resulting dinner
soon thereafter we discovered a solution
to
dinner problems at least we had a little
money in our pockets which was to go to
Clarks Dairy which I hope is still here
if you tell me it's not I'll be
heartbroken I'm leaving right now but
but we would go and we would order a
chicken souvlaki garlic bread and a
Greek salad and we would just share that
and we would just eat it so like
hungrily that the waitress would just
bring us unlimited amounts of garlic
bread and it was like one of my favorite
meals so we have like a limitless supply
of memories from New Haven I want to set
up my discussion with you today by
saying just sharing something that
happened shortly after I left New Haven
I went to work at the US Department of
the Treasury and I had been working at
Treasury for maybe a year when I was
asked to go to Oak Ridge National
Laboratory in Tennessee how many of you
have heard of Oak Ridge
okay so Oak Ridge National Laboratory is
one of the laboratories in the US
National Lab system they develop
technology for the u.s. of the US
government they also play an important
role in the nuclear weapons
infrastructure in the country they
enrich uranium and so what was I doing
at Oak Ridge National Lab you might be
asking so in the early post-war a post
Cold War era so we're talking the late
1990s now the National Labs were looking
for new ways to purpose their technology
their infrastructure of scientists and
researchers and machinery and
possibilities for innovation and they've
gotten interested in potentially
exploring partnerships with agencies in
the US government that worked on law
enforcement they also were interested in
working with the Energy Department which
they were part of to maybe develop new
ideas about sources of energy so there I
was representing Maine Treasury with ATF
agents with me ATF was at the time a
part of the Treasury the agency that did
firearms regulation and enforcement and
we were asking questions about the labs
technology how it could affect a
phenomenon that was garnering growing
interest called climate change and
amidst these conversations we were on a
bus moving through the labs the physical
space of the lab which is in this
ridges and hills and in rural Tennessee
very beautiful and fenced off and then
the announcer on the bus says oh by the
way or any of you who are interested
that over there is the y-12 building
that's the building where they actually
do the enriching of uranium and it made
an impression on me I thought about a
family friend who had lived through the
Nagasaki explosion in Japan as a child
and couldn't herself had children as a
result when I got back to DC I walked
over to Kramer books and picked up a
copy of Robert Oppenheimer's
correspondence it's incredible I
recommend it highly if you have any
bandwidth at all
Oppenheimer is a very complicated man he
studied Sanskrit and physics and his
letters from you know from his youth up
to the time that he was working on
nuclear weapons development a replete
with reflections and a sense of the
tragedy and the beauty of the world a
sense of how gorgeous New Mexico was but
also the sense of tension he felt as he
could almost anticipate what the world
was heading towards and it made him feel
excited and concerned in a way so years
after my visit to Oak Ridge I got a call
that felt to me like it's some kind of
bomb although I'm guilty of saying it
that way given the seriousness of the
topic but I was asked by a major
university to give a commencement
address to the students and somehow in
the weeks that followed that invitation
my trip to Oak Ridge came back to my
mind and I thought about how somehow I
was so fascinated by the sense of
possibility there the scientists and how
creative they were the sense of joy they
had about their work their eagerness to
find new ways to get their knowledge to
be useful for the world but also an
[Music]
ineluctable quality of a sense of coming
up really close to the industrial
production aspect of war and how painful
and damaging that can be at times as
well as protective of our country so so
I had this sense of trying to write a
speech that would somehow give voice to
that but I found that as I got closer
closer to the date of giving that speech
there was another impulse that competed
with that and it was that other impulse
a sense of humbly being so appreciative
for the life that I've had and the
chance to be in this country that
ultimately won out so I want to read you
just a couple of paragraphs of what I
said that day when I finally got up
there and faced a whole bunch of
students and it turned out to be 102
degrees which made me want to rush
through the speech as much as I could I
don't feel that pressure today and I
said think of the world as it stood when
FDR was a baby back then nearly 40% of
children around the world died before
age 5 today
only 4% of children do as my grandfather
was teaching himself to read in rural
Mexico or century ago global literacy
was 12% now it's 85% of the world's
population that can read in her northern
Mexican kitchen my grandmother worked
miracles with corn cilantro tomato
cilantro peppers and sadly lard her own
grandparents could have scarcely
imagined the bounty of nutrition at her
fingertips that so much food is grown by
so few people is a miracle making it
possible for us to study artificial
intelligence and our art history we make
so much water clean enough to drink that
we can literally shower in it as we
celebrate your graduation we have the
means to enjoy lives that are not only
more fulfilling but twice as long on
average as when my grandfather was born
you were the heirs to this gift of
progress across time and for some of us
across borders it's a testament to
creativity to science to our ability to
understand that affect how society
changes over the merest instant of
historical time my father's father began
life as a shepherd in rural northern
Mexico and had no formal education
leaving his parents at 12 he struggled
to make it to the border city where I
would eventually be born and later he
worked to create a municipal waterworks
bringing the city clean water
he faced not only engineering problems
with the complacency and corruption that
to this day can frustrate even the most
laudable efforts to improve public
health
yet he succeeded in the end and clean
water helped strengthen
the city's health literally and
figuratively let me now add that not
everything I mentioned was honey and
roses in that speech of course I talked
about economic inequality I talked about
how disconnected universities could feel
from the world around them I did my best
to treat this as a point of departure
for a conversation about the need for
sharp awareness of the people and
situations we might encounter in our
lives that are just at the very edge of
our awareness and how it's important not
to let them be airbrushed out of our
thinking peripheral vision would help us
see the world as filled with nuances and
subtleties and yet the larger context I
sketched out was one of enormous
progress making me sound in that riff a
bit like a TED talk from Professor
Steven Pinker but I never found a way
that day to work in the disconcerting
reflections from my visit to Oak Ridge
that's what I want to do tonight
in the form of a partial rebuttal to at
least one interpretation of my remarks
in 2017 I want to convey a reminder of
just how messy the world is how
imperfectly our laws policies and social
conventions are serving us as we go
about trying to make the world better
a physicist once eviscerated a paper by
saying it was so bad it wasn't even
wrong we don't say that in law but
sometimes folks think that and I hope to
avoid that here but I want to just
basically share with you my perspective
on why the world being as messy as it is
and as beautiful as it is is full of
peril and full of unresolved problems
that I want to particularly highlight
two that keep me up at night and I hope
that they generate concern for you as
well I'm gonna do that mostly in the
first talk in the second talk I'll talk
about a related problem which also
bedevils a lot of what I've worked on
over the course of my career which is
how we go about weighing costs and
benefits when we say something is the
right thing for people to do in society
the right policy the right regulatory
rule the right judicial decision when
the law gives some opportunity for the
weighing of costs and benefits also to
some extent how another castle lecturer
who came and talked about effective
altruism how those very concepts about
weighing costs and benefits might play a
role in our own lives and why they're
more complicate
they look and the last talk I want to
try to bring that together and apply it
to very exciting and dynamic source of
human ingenuity right now artificial
intelligence and what that might mean if
we take seriously not only our own
limitations but it's its own limitations
so so that's why I hope that you show up
some of you not just today but I'm glad
you're here today so let's talk for a
minute about what the world looks like
humans today are indeed heirs to a world
of almost unimaginable wealth and
technological capacity relative to what
to three generations ago experienced
though we also contend with staggering
tragedy and inequality we've achieved
dominance over our planets to the extent
that you know that you see in that you
experience in your lives we've seen
extreme poverty declined substantially
in just a few generations if you go back
further than a few generations so
further than a hundred and fifty years
of course the picture looks more
complicated as Professor Jim Scott from
Yale reminds us in one of my favorite
recent books against the grain many
people didn't find the early stages of
modern sedentary civilization like all
that fun and enjoyable for individuals
and even large populations almost any
coherent account of their well-being
often showed declines or low levels of
growth for centuries and even millennia
not to mention kind of existential
questions about what the meaning of life
is when you are not free and wild and to
some extent experiencing a degree of
flexibility that you don't when you have
to go to work and you have to till the
land and life begins to look very very
differently
all that said the foundations that were
laid over those centuries made possible
extraordinary progress and the latter
stages of the Industrial Revolution have
made us heirs to just incredible power
and wealth but the picture is
complicated if you look more closely and
it strikes me as quite bold to presume
that several centuries of progress as
against hundreds of thousands of years
of humanity are guaranteed to last and
to keep this trend going much like it is
species suffer when they can't adapt to
the environment and avoiding calamity
takes effort and concern sometimes born
frankly from fear so what's more even
the recent picture is complicated
between 1960 and 2015 global gigatonnes
of co2 emissions have gone from 10 to
over to just under 40 a year freshwater
resources per capita have declined from
over 13 cubic kilometers to 6 we have
less than 50% of the vertebrate species
relative to what existed in 1970 even as
we recognize that hundreds of millions
of people are living better lives
relative to just 5 decades ago if we're
honest we can also hear jarring sounds
of distress not just persisting but
growing between 1960 and 2010 the
percentage of black men in America
without a high school diploma that were
between the ages of 25 or 29 so black
men no high school diploma between ages
25 and 29 who incarcerated grew from 7%
to a total of about 33% in America the
comparable percentage for white men
without a diploma same demographic went
from about 3.5 percent to 7 percent and
looming in the background of course the
environmental consequences of the
industrial economy and geopolitics
particularly with respect to not only
climate change but nuclear armaments
grind on from almost any defensible
perspective climate change and the
problems associated with a demand
massive and strategic action even two
degrees an average temperature rise
would devastate many countries
drastically degrade the environments per
mass irregular migration starkly
heightened global wealth inequalities
and require adaptation at staggering
cost all this is so familiar that
actually struggle with how to say it in
a way that doesn't make it sound more
anodyne like I all right there goes
somebody else again talking about the
climate change stuff so I play with the
words and I'm not sure I'm getting it
right but I'll just tell you it really
is striking to me in particular to focus
on what the IPPC
what the IPCC says about what we've
learned are now consequences that we are
seeing with just one degree of warming
relative to the baseline scenario so it
was reasonable to assume until
recently that if we just avoided
anything over two degrees and warming
things would pretty much be fine but one
degree of warming is producing heat
waves heavy precipitation throughout sea
level rise wildfires which are all too
close to home in California agricultural
disruptions disruptions and health
economic growth in conflict the science
behind this is complex and I've looked
at it and I know and you know that
isolating causal effects is really
really tough but it's getting better and
better and more accurate and I would
just say the burden of proof is really
on somebody who wants to say no that's
wrong and then of course at two degrees
Celsius it gets kind of tough right
extreme warming could occur in major
population centers in North America in
the Mediterranean massive chunks of Asia
the report the IPCC report emphasizes
that the closing window of opportunity
is also really salient because at some
point these processes begin to have kind
of a life of their own and even if we
control greenhouse gas emissions and
slow the warming process there's going
to be a piece baked in no pun intended
that will be hard to undo it is easy
enough if you think about it to situate
the origins of climate risk in
industrial capitalism right so like on
the one hand you have to acknowledge
that most of the global emissions as I
understand it that the world has ever
seen have happened since I was in high
school
that's pretty sobering and yet of course
the roots of this go back a lot further
in 1820 almost 90% of the world lived in
extreme poverty defined as living on
less than dollar 90 a day in purchasing
power parity by 2015 the figure that's
comparable is 10% so as a result we're
happier healthier live longer today far
greater percentage can read right vote
that's great but that story is a story
of burning fossil fuels heavily you know
improvements in human lifespans quality
of life etc tend to relate pretty
closely to measures we have fossil fuel
burning when economies transition to
fossil fuels energy scarcity no longer
limited the value of capital inputs nor
the value of outputs to our societies
me unleashing a ton of growth there are
different ways to tell the story but one
thing that caught my attention is a
Swedish study finding that the Swedish
economy increased energy supply and that
was the most important driver of growth
in that country between 1800 and 1950
where the rapid increase in the use of
electricity coal and oil in 1900
produced GDP per capita growth of 2.5 up
from 0.7 so different ways to tell the
story but fossil fuel-burning helped
economic growth and also encouraged a
ton of pollution negative externalities
familiar to anybody in this room there
are a familiar feature of how our
markets work markets are structured
through equally familiar institutions
like courts and all kinds of rules that
lead to iterative technological progress
much of it spurred by this combustible
cycle of burning stuff and generating
energy just as familiar are the
inequities built into the structure of
the international system that contribute
to profound and subtle climate risk
experienced differently by people in
different parts of the world
so as Lea greenfield and other scholars
persuasively argue it takes the kind of
national narrative making individuals
feel identified with national groups to
build the kind of massive infrastructure
of roads electric power market
institutions enabling industrial
economic growth of the scale we now have
borders make it easy for some countries
to externalize climate risk because the
cost of climate change aren't
distributed evenly so by some fairly
conservative estimates it's likely the
climate change will push more than 120
million people into poverty by 2030 the
countries that have burned the most
fossil fuel will tend not to experience
the most severe climate risks and of
course geopolitical competition is given
country is a big incentive for economic
growth okay far from the headlines but
close to activation nuclear weapons
capable of wreaking enormous damage on
civilization as we know it are readily
deployed and subject to rickety command
and control systems in many parts of the
world
a reasonable premise is that any serious
use of nuclear weapons frankly any use
of nuclear weapons would have a
staggering effect on the world not only
because of the potential loss of life
and environmental consequences but
because of the likely impact on global
norms despite a reduction in nuclear
armaments of about 80 percent since the
end of the Cold War the Arsenal's of the
United States and Russia still include
thousands of nuclear weapons in 2017
there were an estimated nine thousand
two hundred and twenty nuclear weapons
in the world according to The Bulletin
of Atomic Scientists the possibility of
their use seems really quite remote to
anybody in this room but the risks of
accidental launch are not unfamiliar
from tightly coupled systems and mishaps
that we experience during the Cold War
so let me start by just noting that it's
worth taking a step back and recognizing
what the command and control structure
is even in a country that keeps very
tight control of these weapons like say
the United States right no international
treaty explicitly stops the u.s. from
using its nuclear weapons should the
president decide to do so no federal law
requires the president to obtain
anybody's approval before using nuclear
weapons maybe understandably given the
scenarios that we imagine that might
trigger use of nuclear weapons nothing
prevents the president from unilaterally
deciding to do so the president has the
option of consulting with military
advisors in the short amount of time
that perhaps he or she might have before
choosing to use weapons in an emergency
but the president doesn't have to do
that they are obligated his military
advisors under the Uniform Code of
Military Justice to follow the orders of
their superior officers which in this
case would include the president the
president is obligated to abide by the
law of war in any decision that use
nuclear weapons just as the president
would be obliged to follow the laws of
war in conventional settings and you
know all this risks turning the use of
nuclear weapons into a kind of informal
adjudication as we would
administrative law then there's a risk
of accidents so in 1980 maintenance
workers conducting maintenance on the
us's then largest nuclear missile
facility accidentally dropped a wrench
off of a platform elevated more than 70
feet in the air the wrench punctured the
side of the missile which allowed highly
combustible rocket fuel to spill out
onto the side of the missile the
mechanics working on the missile did not
immediately tell their superiors what
had happened allowing more and more
pressurized fuel to leak before officers
on the site knew what the problem was or
why alarms were sounding eventually
enough fuel leaked out that the missile
collapsed resulting in a massive
explosion the nuclear warhead did not
detonate when the incident came to light
the US government's official position
was that there was no way that it could
have detonated if it had the explosion
would have killed millions of people in
Arkansan adjacent states including Yale
Law School graduates Arkansas governor
Bill Clinton and Hillary Clinton who
were just 50 miles away at the Arkansas
Democratic convention and of course
history's continued to give us some
reminders that normal accidents happen
in this context as Yale sociologist
chick Perot would say these are familiar
risks but novel ones are also part of
the picture as stockpile stewardship
replaces aging analog infrastructure
with complex digital systems we can
warmly welcome the nuclear
infrastructure into the evolving arms
race of cybersecurity and then there's
the advent of nuclear weapons in
countries like Pakistan where command
and control gives enormous power to
military officials and perhaps even
field commanders despite falling total
stockpiles several countries including
Russia and Pakistan have all begun
pursuing the development of new tactical
nuclear weapons in efforts to modernize
their Arsenal's as with climate it's
worth acknowledging that some
communities have been especially hard
hit by the price that civilization is
paid for nuclear weapons consider the
intersecting effects of climate and
nuclear in some of the places that
people call home around the world
between 1946 and 1958 the United States
detonated 67 nuclear bombs in or right
above the Marshall
Islands now about 5,000 miles west of my
home state there sits a vast concrete
dome that the American government built
to hold the worst of the nuclear waste
that was produced including lethal
concentrations of plutonium the LA Times
recently also reported that the 3.1
million cubic feet of waste include a
special extra bonus 130 tons of
irradiated soil shipped from Nevada to
the Marshall Islands
as glaciers melt around the world and
sea level rises waves are lapping at the
edges of the dome a recent study by
researchers from Columbia showed
radiation in some areas of the atoll
where the dome is located as comparable
to those found in Fukushima and
Chernobyl a tribunal established by the
US and the Marshall Islands to address
these issues in 1988 ordered the u.s. to
pay 2.3 billion dollars but the US has
paid four million dollars so far it's
tempting to situate responsibility for a
nuclear balance of terror in the drama's
of the mid 20th century especially world
war 2 and the Cold War Robert
Oppenheimer's platoon of physicists many
of them Jewish would not have decamp to
Los Alamos without Hitler's Germany as a
threat and of course it's telling that
the army kept the weakness of the German
nuclear program secret from the
scientists who were doing their work in
Los Alamos from those beginnings it was
the Cold War that then scaled nuclear
weapons into what Daniel Ellsberg has
called the doomsday machine to deny how
these quirks of history shaped the
nuances of our nuclear balance and world
would ignore the origins of our physical
nuclear infrastructure the importance of
the peculiar Club of declared nuclear
powers the meaning of pivotal
confrontations such as between General
MacArthur and Truman about using nuclear
weapons in Korea or Curtis LeMay and
Kennedy about the role of nuclear
threats and the strategy for the Cuban
Missile Crisis yet as with climate
change reporters on madness to ignore
the deeper forces generating and
sustaining global nuclear risk the
industrial economy made possible Oak
Ridge and the rest of the elaborate
infrastructure enabling nuclear weapons
nationalism and GOP
resources sustained policies that led to
tensions in competition among
increasingly technologically advanced
countries those features of global life
of almost certainly contributed to the
bounty from the industrial economy given
security concerns and country's desire
for global political advantage and the
ability of states to remain different
and compete on multiple dimensions
allowed us to experience the growth of
experimentation and society and
expansion that has contributed to the
experiencing global scale of knowledge
about how to govern sensibly at the same
time it's perhaps not impossible but
quite difficult to tell a persuasive
story where all these features of social
life were present and somehow Enrico
Fermi's atomic pile at the University of
Chicago demonstrating a chain reaction
doesn't lead to the development of a
weapon my claim is simply that if we
want to narrate a story of considerable
human progress into roughly existing
conditions with no nuclear risk it's
really not easy to show that fully
evaluating the welfare implications of
geopolitics is difficult because it's
hard to do the counterfactual but if
anybody wants to treat our current
accomplishments and civilization as
somehow something that we can easily
take a scalpel to and simply take
nuclear risk out of the equation I'd say
they have quite a bit of explaining to
do the fertility of the modern
industrial economy the possibility is
associated with the international system
that we have of geopolitical competition
have left us some byproducts that feel
toxic and it's far from clear that we
can take that scalpel and simply do
without them so I want to close by
simply sharing a few thoughts about
where we go from here what it is that
perhaps might help us overcome some of
these difficulties and what difficult
questions are then entangled in those
domains let me talk first about social
movements practically oriented analysts
of how the world changes know how
pivotal social movements have been to
long-term evolutions of policy in law
and civil rights the treatment of women
public health it's true enough that such
movements can constrain this course and
risk disrupt
but of course there's a profound upside
to their potential impact as well we
need to consider how social movements
combining principled aspirations and
personal interests have motivated a
large scale change in the past and what
we can learn from that with respect to
climate nuclear weapons or any other
risk that the world faces the potential
for social movements to affect the
history of nuclear armaments and climate
change raises newel nuanced questions
about timing and geography the
possibilities are nonetheless plain from
Charles Tilly's eloquent description of
three elements such movements tend to
reflect a sustained organized public
effort making collective claims on
target authorities let us call it a
campaign employment of combinations
including creations of special-purpose
associations and coalition's public
meetings solemn processionals vigils
rallies demonstrations petition drives
in statements to and from the public
media and participants concerted public
display of what he calls WNC worthiness
unity numbers and commitment of course
we can aspire for policy entrepreneurs
teachers philanthropists and activists
to take data seriously two-way
consequences to spell it alternative
scenarios and channel expert wisdom more
on this in the next lecture but it's
fantasy to think that centrist
technocrats drive most meaningful social
and policy change at least in a
pluralist society and arguably in many
other societies a more accurate story
would tend to place a meaningful set of
responsibilities and causal explanations
for social change in the reciprocal
effects that arise between key
constituencies in the general public
responding to shared concerns leaders of
social movements lawyers policymakers
technical experts responding to the
pressures that they feel that's almost
certainly even more true with respect to
climate and nuclear for the former the
public's actions are profoundly
implicated and the cost of transition
substantial despite the increasingly
favorable economics of cleaner energy
channeling passion and generating a
sense
possibility overcome futility on this
front is like salt is to a New Haven
pizza for the latter the risk generally
is far away from the newspaper front
pages we rarely print anymore an engaged
public has a potential to change the
political calculus like few other
factors can changing the story is just
now being written without some
considerably greater more galvanized
degree of public concern seems evermore
remote a possibility now let's talk
about paradigms not only social
movements but also elites are to a
considerable extent shaped by the
cross-cutting paradigms about
geopolitics or economics or laws role in
the world that help people make sense of
how the world works to reflect sensibly
on whether we can disentangle the
blessings of modern civilization from
these risks we need to apply not only
our growing knowledge of the risks
themselves but we know about politics
economics institutions and society we
especially need to apply that knowledge
to help us learn from how difficult it
is for people to imagine the
manifestation of risks or to understand
how much Social Welfare is
interdependent in an existing framework
of economics and politics that might
make it difficult for the world to
imagine a different setting GDP for
instance is only a little less crude as
a measure of social well-being than to
measure
victories in Harvard Yale football games
this is a measure of Yale's well-being
I'm overstating this slightly but I see
both room and urgency for connecting
policymaking more thoroughly with
perceptive nuanced measures of
well-being that can leverage discussions
about genuine progress it's telling that
according to Lutz and kebaya day for
example improved education as a better
predictor of increased life expectancy
than per capita GDP new thinking about
political economy will not only help
ease the challenges associated with
climate change but will likely
contribute to our conception of global
institutions that may eventually also
help us manage nuclear risk each
paradigm has its characteristic
institutional advances if more decisive
progress on climate change or nuclear
security will require advances in global
institutions we
might ask how might that advance bring
along with it a broader purchase on
translating post neoliberal ideas if you
want to call them that into improve
governance this is not going to be a
linear process with shifts and
institutions and shifts in the
functioning of markets building the
lived experience that paves the way for
a broader institutional and intellectual
change so tonight I've sought to
acknowledge the enormous social progress
that makes our ambitious legal system
the global Internet and even this
conversation possible but I've also
tried to emphasize an awkward
uncomfortable reality than any candid
evaluation of modern human life must
face up to we have longer lives and more
material wealth in part because we've
burned fuels that pollute and now
imperil the earth and we've organized
societies and the countries that
competes sometimes go to war and in some
cases have the capacity to threaten
nuclear annihilation picture is not
entirely or purely bleak regarding
climate for example the economics of
renewables and efficiency are extremely
attractive recent studies indicate that
renewables are the cheapest new
electricity across most of the world's
energy efficiency is a great investment
almost everywhere on the nuclear front
one house of Congress recently voted to
defund the push for tactical nuclear
weapons yet climate a nuclear or more
urgent than people realize and also much
more entangled in the deep structure of
society the continuous observation and
attention to nuance that I called for
when I address students at commencement
was meant to remind us of the mysteries
around us that stubbornly elude our
grasp if that realization makes us feel
a bit less confident about how exactly
we navigate the dilemmas and bodies by
Oak Ridge perhaps it will also help us
keep a sense of wonder about the small
miracles brimming with secrets about the
fragile world will soon and trust to the
next generation having chicken souvlaki
and garlic bread that Clark's dairy
thank you
I want you to know I almost never come
up to give a talk with more than five
pages so this is unusual and I'm really
grateful that you sat through it so I'd
love to hear what you have to say let's
start over here and tell me your
background and also and how that sort of
relates to your background working in
the judicial branch which I sometimes
and maybe this is a misperception on my
part but I sort of see it as more
isolated from from social movements and
see sort of the legislative means thank
you acquaintances more influenced or
more targets
I can try
that's perceptive and I would say in
some ways it's both important to
recognize that in our system that the
way we narrate how our system is
supposed to work we look to the
judiciary to be apart a little bit more
from society and to be a sort of
Guardian and to be neutral and I don't
disagree that that's an important part
of our tradition and the way we work
that said it's also important to
recognize that even the courts are
buffeted about by the tensions and the
passions and the concerns that people
will sometimes mobilize around now part
of what a court needs to do is to engage
with that in the appropriate way and at
the appropriate time but I notice the
interplay of social mobilization and
litigation and public understanding of
issues around civil rights that played
out in our history in the middle of the
20th century and let me give you an
example that's a little bit kind of
different like kind of out there like
you might think of it as very different
but I view it also as an example of how
social mobilization and the tensions
that affect the public intersect with a
large judiciary so professor Rosenbluth
and I were just talking as we came in
the scale of California's court system
and it's actually truly staggering even
to me after five years of this so
California has 40 million people and we
have about six and a half million cases
maybe a year we have 2,500 judges and
that means that actually having that
system run day to day in an
administrative way to meet the needs of
Californians who might need to go to
court to get a restraining order or to
deal with an elder abuse issue and have
no lawyer or in some cases don't speak
the language so really important
responsibility we have and in that way
courts I would argue should be
responsive to the to the concerns raised
by socially mobilized people who say hey
your legal system says that I should
have my day in court never mind that I
can't speak the language so well or I'm
poor and the courts cannot redress every
problem in society but then being aware
of the fact that 210 languages are
spoken in California that maybe about
seven and a half million Californians
don't speak English very well
that interpreters are needed and not
only criminal but civil proceedings that
feels to me like one of several examples
of where the courts also have a
responsibility to engage with the public
yeah
I was a commercial banker I had six
children 14 grandchildren I moved here
four years ago after my wife Jenna
the state Georgia probably has a
temperature that more than two degrees
hotter than Connecticut is probably six
degrees harder so why isn't that an apt
comparison to say that we couldn't adopt
excuse me that we could adapt aside from
the fact that water flows everywhere
you're not a scientist I know but you're
off you clear thank you well I
appreciate that I wish I were an even
clearer thinker but having grown up in a
climate very similar to George's for at
least part of my life I I know in some
ways exactly what you mean so before I
moved to California I lived in the part
of northern Mexico that's right on the
border with South Texas and the weather
in Georgia and in northern Mexico is
very familiar to me and very similar
it's extremely humid it's very very hot
in the summer and the combination of you
know 96 degree 98 degree weather and a
hot day with 90 something percent
humidity is to me a lot worse than 117
degrees in the desert but with a lot of
dryness which I also experienced so it's
a fair question for that reason and I
gather from my colleagues who are
scientists that the real issue has to do
with the fact that these these degree
warming figures are really global
averages that are masking enormous
variation around the world right so it's
less an issue of does the temperature on
average just nudge upwards everywhere
the same way just one or two degrees
hotter it's more like tweak the
temperature a little bit and big changes
might happen in risk of wildfire or in
the likelihood of additional
precipitation or in the impact on a
glacier that then as it melts releases
certain combination of chemicals that
then speeds up the further release of
additional gases that then create
further greenhouse gas sort of global
warming type effects so it's a it's a
very crude measure of something that
actually is more subtle that the more
subtle point is what are the forces that
are driving global climate and I will
say not being a scientist I try my best
to sort of look into this with prudence
as somebody who's mostly trying to
survey like what is a scientific
consensus but I'll just give you one
example of how how this is becoming an
interesting and difficult question for
the courts and why I started trying to
get more deep into trying to understand
these forces so California decided
through a democratic process to set
targets on the reduction of greenhouse
gas emissions but there's a continuing
challenge in taking that set of targets
that play out over 20 25 years and
matching it up to the environmental
review process that California requires
for land-use decisions so if you want to
build 5,000 homes in Santa Clarita
California then the environmental review
you have to do has to address a set of
question of environmental questions that
might be relevant to whether the state
can meet its environmental commitments
so how do you take these greenhouse gas
emissions goals that the state is set
and somehow judicata like who's
responsible for what proportion of that
in building projects I must say like I
find that a really humbling a difficult
challenge but it's an example of why it
is that scientists and judges need to
work together to understand each other's
worlds
yes I was partly also talking to
professor Rosenblatt when I came in
about the differences in the educational
experience I had in law school versus
PhD so I'll start with that I thought
when I was an undergrad that crazy
though it seemed to try to get both
degrees one reason to do it would be
that law school would be really
practical I'd learn a set of skills
about trial practice I'd learn how to
take it that position I'd learned how to
plan an oral argument I'd learn how to
decipher a statute and then PhD would be
a chance to sort of have those
discussions that I love to have as an
undergrad about how does the world work
who's responsible for what what's moral
and ethical like how do you measure
changes in political behavior and I
found that it did not actually work out
that way entirely partly Yale Law School
in particular is a little quirky right
so there's a lot of discussing and
academic thinking going on there was
also a terrific clinic which is where I
learned to be kind of a lawyer and
professor was there was sort of at the
core of that he taught he was one of the
faculty members in the trial practice
program and just kind of helped all of
us were in the clinic try to draw some
connection between the more theoretical
stuff we were learning in the classroom
and like what do you do when you have to
deliver bad news to a client and they
don't want to hear and you don't want to
say it but you have to be honest with
them over time I found that there's one
way in which both Law School and PhD
really converged and then there's a Noah
way in which they're very different
where they converge design interested
instruction I'm interested not only in
what it is that people think is a good
idea but I'm interested in the forces
around them that allow that idea to be
expressed and acted on and to thrive
versus to crash and burn in a way and
those forces can range from
economics to politics and political
pressure and law enforcement like any
number of things peer groups etc in that
respect I feel like both law school and
the ph.d program in their own ways were
concerned with that I had a phenomenal
teacher in law school who was a visiting
professor when I was here and sadly has
passed away now William stunts what I
loved about him is he actually like
brought together perfectly the the PhD
in political science side although he
wasn't a political scientist he thought
like one and the doctrinal lawyer
because he would be talking about what
it is a court required from courts when
they were overseeing the way police
might have interrogated a suspect and
then he'd step out of that and say what
are the pressures for a police
department in that situation what are
cops actually gonna do how are they
gonna understand those instructions so
that's only in which they come again the
way a to verge is that the PhD in
political science was mostly not
normative it was mostly about what
forces are effecting political behavior
in the world law has a normative
component what is the right way to read
a statute what's the wrong way to
interpret a constitution what would be
wrong for a court to do that maybe a
Legislature should do so as judge I've
drawn that training a lot and recognize
that political science might inform my
understanding of how a court decision
might be perceived or what pressures a
court might be under but I have to
create a space where I can turn that off
and I can think more profoundly about
being like a fiduciary in a way and
trying to protect an honor a set of
traditions we have to make sure that
they don't get cast aside I'm glad
people are raising their hands because
there's a law professor of course I can
call on people to
logically really excited this series my
name is grace I'm also a junior
I guess my question mainly draws from
this kind of like our movements very
recently particularly we saw protests
based but it still feels like to me
nuclear very driven decisions and
movements from different feeling I think
it's a good question it's a challenging
one
let me start by gently suggesting an
amendment to one aspect of your premise
this is I'm about to share like what I'm
most confident about in answering your
question and beyond that my level of
confidence drops a bit climate is very
bottom up like you could say part of my
message is that there's no question that
there's a policy component to how the
world has come to be in this situation
but I think even more important than the
policy decision-making has been a set of
social processes some of them around the
logic of economic growth some of them
around consumer behavior
some of them around how we allocate
responsibilities to each other or nots
such that it's kind of a collective
action problem and we all have had our
various reasons to do things not because
we don't care about the climate but
because we began to wonder well how does
my change in my behavior really affect
the whole picture and then do I have an
incentive to stop doing what I'm doing
or am I really even fully aware I mean
it's a version of the problem I was
describing earlier of allocating an
emissions reduction target to a set of
much narrower circumstances and that
institutional problem to me is at the
heart of a climate situation one of the
corollaries of it now is the the very
real challenge of contending with
billions of people who have yet to fully
enjoy the gains of having achieved what
we would call middle-class status in an
advanced industrialized country who are
like yeah I don't want the planet to you
know be in crisis for climate reasons
but I also don't want to have a
constraint on my people's ability to
prosper in the way that people already
before me have when they were able to
burn a whole bunch of stuff and the
nuanced policy questions around that I
think need to be informed by a bottom-up
process of engaging with people whose
trust we will need if that is going to
be carried off because otherwise like
California we like to say to people it's
a fifth largest economy in the world if
you measure it a certain way and yes it
is but what we do is going to be
meaningless in comparison to the
decisions that are made in places like
China and India right now now I think
that the other part of your question
which remains challenging to me is
nuclear does feel to me more like driven
top-down although not without a
component of responses to popular
ferments like Afghanistan not
Afghanistan Pakistan might be an example
of that dynamic to some extent India but
but then what do we do about it and I
guess my step one would be we care about
it right like I think that's it seems
like a cop-out to say that but I don't
think we're I'm mostly not talking about
nuclear like it doesn't show up in my
docket so much but it shows up in my
conversations with my kids and makes me
wonder about how it is that our popular
discourse is really giving us a full
picture of what it is that we need and I
think the next step is particularly if
we're lucky enough to be in settings
where we're protected enough to have
room to think deep thoughts and to work
with other smart people to sort of
sketch it out like what are you gonna do
about it when you're a policymaker
someday and you actually find yourself
surprised one day to realize that then
your jurisdiction is not purely about
this but it actually begins to get you
closer to this maybe you're the US
ambassador to NATO or maybe you work in
a big foundation and you're deciding
whether international secure
problem to deal with and there I think
we need all the help we can get and you
know it's telling to me the even the
George Shultz's and Sam Nunn's of the
world so I can't talk really about
litigation because some of these things
might in some form end up before my
court but I can tell you a couple things
that feel to me important one of the
burdens of anybody who is calling for
social movements to play an appropriate
role in social change you see then
recognize that there is a tension
between the highly technical and
protected decision-making that tends to
have to happen in courts or judicata in
cases like that and the fervor and
intensity and anger that people have
about any set of actions so I think
that's difficult and I feel like it's
important for courts to be able to say
sometimes like well you know it's not
our job to ultimately decide the merits
of the policy itself it's our job to
figure out what the parameters really
fairly are but I will also say something
else without getting into the merits of
litigation and that is it feels to me
like an important achievement of our
legal system is to
have built as a mechanism for reason
giving for a lot of important decisions
that are made by executive decision
makers to be subjected to a kind of
dialogue where we ask what were your
reasons and that is an important part of
a process to disentangle where is their
crafts partisanship or where is their no
motive at all in other than just sort of
anger or frustration or a desire to
appease a certain part of the public and
where there's actually some degree of
thinking and that thinking could include
a sort of civic judgement about what it
is that the country needs it's not all
technical I will talk about that
tomorrow but it does feel to me that
that interplay puts judges sometimes in
a very tricky place but one that needs
to be carefully protected yes awareness
of change seems twice as high this year
as it was a year ago is that anywhere
near fast enough or should you who are
so articulate take leadership in the
United States of America to create more
urgency should little people like I all
right I've got a job that I like very
much but I and I think ultimately I can
there's some things I can say about this
as a kind of scholar and some things
that have to sort of remain for my day
job but I do feel like you raised a good
question again about this interplay of
social movements and then like the
second point I made is largely about
paradigms of thought right which is a
different kind of work in a different
kind of leadership and like where does
leadership come from and I must say like
I think a lot in terms of coalition
building so let me give you one
experience that I had working in the
Obama administration on criminal justice
issues somewhat different than what
we're talking about now certainly a role
very different from the role that I have
as a judge but there was a bit of an
overlap and that you have to listen to
different voices and the issue
specifically there was about drug
sentences so it's
we familiar to a lot of you that when
when when punishments are doled out for
drug crimes historically there had been
a time in our history where crack
cocaine offenses were punished very very
very differently from powder cocaine
offenses there still in some
jurisdictions the disparity and how he
punished these but for a while in the in
the federal system the disparity if you
look at quantities that were necessary
to trigger particular penalties were
disparate is like a hundred to one and
so when the president that I worked for
was running for office he did mention
this issue as one issue on which he
wanted to try to work for change when he
became president it became clear to any
number of us working with the president
that the bandwidth that we had to do
anything near all the promises that he
would made was not there you had to be
like a lot of the jobs seemed to be
early on picking which issues were
possible to work on given the window of
possibilities that existed at the time
and so working with some colleagues at
the apartment justice we had some work
to do in persuading our colleagues in
the administration that this was an
issue that the administration had the
bandwidth to move forward on to be yeah
so so that took some discussion of ideas
like the theory of change as it were
that we floated was that it this
mattered not only because of the people
who might be affected in the federal
system but also in the states right the
vast majority of criminal prosecutions
happen in the states in some change in
policy responsibly done with bipartisan
support at the federal level it could be
the kind of signal that might encourage
some states to take another look at
these things and so that the impact
could be multiplied that level of by and
led to that a strategy of trying to move
this forward but in a way that was as
bipartisan as possible which admittedly
was easier done then than now but there
was a crucial few weeks months where the
folks who are working on this in
Congress as well as those of us in the
administration had meetings with
advocacy groups and we have to base
we tried to help them see that some of
the ways in which this could best move
forward but actually lower the
temperature of the issue wouldn't be to
bring as much attention to it it would
be to actually recognize that already a
lot of attention had been moved to it
and now it was about building a
coalition that would bring others
together from the other party and there
was some disagreement about that but
ultimately some understanding that that
was necessary and that probably helped
get this enacted with a bipartisan vote
on a voice vote in the Senate Judiciary
Committee get it through the Senate
quickly get it to the house quickly
before floor time ran so I draw two
lessons from that oh by the way also
another crucial piece of that was
evangelical Christian leadership I was
in many ways quite supportive of this as
were libertarian conservatives so the
coalition building was difficult but it
was crucial so one lesson that I draw
from this is that there is no solving
this problem without pulling along
people who disagree about a lot of
things and that takes a lot of listening
and a lot of hard work and a lot of
careful trust-building first the second
lesson to me is that this is partly
about ideas it's partly about forging a
common language that gets people to
understand to what extent their own
interests are really impacted by this
you know I don't I don't think that's a
perfect answer but at least it
highlights some of what I think is part
of the answer that doesn't lend itself
to trying to seduce rather than impose
this like you know for all of us who
think of the separation of powers as
being pretty important in American life
Congress does one thing the executor
says another I will say ruefully that
when you're in the executive branch
sometimes you feel like it's so
frustrating
how much process there is to get certain
things done and you look hard at what
you can legally do using executive
authority legally but sometimes I think
the history of Congress is revealing
because it's not just about what can you
get done with executive authority even
if it's legal to
that it's also about how can you build a
coalition a support that is likely to
protect what you've done in a way that
it's going to transcend one or two or
three or seven administrations it's tons
of fun
I recommend it yes question thank you
for coming thank you so much I really
enjoyed youth hall I'm Bradley I'm a
major in ethics politics and economics
analyst and computer science um
you were talking a little bit about the
possibility of advancing global
institutions in creating structures that
might address these larger problems and
assail all of us as so humanity and not
just America as a nation it has real
hardening for me because I'm not from
America Singapore I'm studying at Yale
by fine American institutions and
American history and of course the
American political order extremely
important and significant for for your
allies and your friends have brought my
concern in particular was the climate
change is that we're currently operating
and a sort of super political model or
by sustainable growth is still sort of
possible if we limit our co2 emissions
such that the rise in temperature
remains below one point five to two
degrees as that window closes the game
starts to change and we begin to get
into a sort of zero-sum winners and
losers game if we go beyond three
degrees and I was wondering how how
would glow belen institutions are how
would more developed countries of which
from a country that has definitely
benefited a lot from the global
distribution and has incredibly high GDP
per capita so this is on my head as well
how do we bear responsibility or think
about what we owe others in a situation
where sustainable growth is no longer a
possibility where it is really kind of a
dog-eat-dog world and there are going to
be sort of millions of people who are
displaced and who don't have a
possibility of possibility for further
development simply because the
situation's just just gone too too bad
my first choice is that we all do our
part and we don't get to that point but
I I think you know many people in your
generation or even younger could ask the
question with even more of an edge
you've asked it very diplomatically and
I welcome that and I appreciate that
because I think diplomacy is important
as well as urgency but here's the
restated version that is more urgent in
a way you could say my generation comes
along and I'm experiencing like this
great massive fork in the road and one
path leads to a place where I people who
are part of my generation not gonna get
to live the kind of life that we might
have otherwise been able to for reasons
that are not of our making primarily so
what do you do about that
your generation meaning mine to some
extent and we'll all of us do about it
because if we don't you know you're not
fully the one that's gonna pay the full
price and I'm not saying that's that's
all that you're saying but I think
there's an element of your question that
has that in it and rightly so like I I'm
still struggling with just grant coming
in terms with what it means to have like
most of the greenhouse gas emissions in
the history of humanity having come as I
understand it since I was in high school
right but but but let me sort of say a
word or two about what happens before a
tipping point and how to think about
after a tipping point so before a
tipping point there's an interplay of
self-interested action and moral and
ethical reasoning and much of what you
do in ethics politics and economics is
to think about how and why and when
those are blended together and when
they're actually in tension with each
other
to do about that I I hope that by
evoking social movements I'm both
suggesting the need for more compelling
storytelling and and believable
narratives about interest about who is
paying what price and why it's in our
interest like up to it including the
economic possibilities our new
renewables but also including like
prices that we will pay in a you know
time horizon that is not so remote but I
also mean to evoke the idea that some
moral and ethical reasoning is important
I had hope to believe that when when I'm
trying my best to make sense of what is
happening in my own state I'm looking at
legislative history that shows not only
California's concern for its own
wildfires but concern for people who are
thousands of miles away however
imperfectly executed but I think it is
not a lie that you see that and that
feels to me like that's something we can
build up right like there there are
going to be times when the better
narrative is to say no don't think about
it in moral terms just be honest like
the returns to clean energy are
extraordinary like just stuff to see it
in a clearer way and maybe not be
subsidizing this y'see so much in their
times when we all have to limit some of
what we'd otherwise love to do after the
tipping point I mean you know query what
tipping point you pick but because
they're separate but tipping points
evoke to me in my most optimistic
moments massive public health
emergencies of a disastrous scale and I
will say that the world can and has
mobilized around those that the World
Health Organization is not a perfect
organization but countries cooperate and
they have a lot vested in stopping
something that is going to affect them
all and it's going to make them
vulnerable in ways that they do not want
and so makes me feel like they're I
don't take for granted the fragility or
the impossibility of building some
shared cooperation even in the system of
sovereign nations that we have and that
we celebrate right so it feels to me
like laying the groundwork for that so
that if and when
that shift happens we can take advantage
of that infrastructure in a compelling
way is also worth a lot of kind of devil
in the details sort of work what
organizations what career tracks who
goes to work where you know what's the
legal superstructure to do that what
countries are going to be part of what
coalitions how to share the cost and so
on great and by the way somebody said
ridiculously cool I feel this is
ridiculous equal to like it is just
marvelous for me to have the chance to
have this conversation and you're having
an impact on me that is a very good
question here I I will say before I was
the on the court I was the head of
institution Stanford I called the
Freeman spogli Institute which was an
Institute for International Studies
comparable probably to what you have at
Yale and that institution to my great
delight had a center called the Center
on food security in the environment
which we ran jointly with Stanford's
interdisciplinary Institute on the
environment and it was one of my
favorite places in the Institute because
it was like the perfect meeting ground
of policy and hard core science and I
hired some of the people that do this
sort of work so I can tell you some of
the methods that they use but but there
are people who are more expert than I am
that can tell you more details so some
of what you do is use simulations you
aggregate data about how climate effects
have had economic impacts on people
around access to food around changes in
economic livelihoods around economic
social and and political and violent
conflict to some extent around migration
patterns and you begin to see how those
secondary effects have an effect on
who's above and below the poverty line
so then you make estimates with some
band of confidence and you adjust those
over time as additional data come in
the ability we have to use new methods
to pinpoint this was somewhat greater
confidence has really increased in the
last three to four years so one
technique is satellite images which we
can then match up with fairly precise
pictures of weather and climates so
we're beginning to develop a sort of
global body of knowledge around how how
the effect happens but I think the main
takeaway intellectually relative to your
question is it's not one effect one sort
of like causal pathway it's partly food
partly economics partly conflict partly
even we're beginning to see the
cognitive impacts of heat on people's
ability to do productive work so there's
a kind of frontier we're pushing outward
and it's kind of encouraging to me how
much we're learning but it's not
encouraging what room yeah
I just wanted like why you seem to have
so much faith in these social movements
especially since they've been around for
a while thank you and I should say it's
kind of ironic you say what you do about
and how much optimism I have because I
think of myself as leaning in the
optimistic direction often and as I was
writing this I thought this sounds so
depressing with so like not like me and
and it did feel like a weird sort of
coda to things I've said at times that
that emphasized a little bit more like
let's remember the context were all
errors of this extraordinary progress
and civilization let's not wasted so so
I don't mean to sound overly optimistic
I think this is a not-self problem and
we're sharing it like I I want to at
least acknowledge that I I feel it like
I think mostly in my day job it gets
channeled into particular cases and
applying particular bodies of law that
are democratically enacted but as a
scholar I feel like I have a need to be
aware of it and a need to think about
how the disciplines in which I work
institutional history and development
political science public law you know
cyber law how all those fields are
grappling with this because I think of
it as cutting across everything we do
and yet I will actually gently argue
with a little bit of the premise of your
question in the following way so I think
there's let me start with with political
economy paradigms and then I'll move to
social movements I I would really
challenge anyone to tell me that
political economy paradigms like how we
think about supply and demand or how we
think about market failure have had no
effect on policymaking I would in fact
argue that they've had enormous effect
in part because they hum and work in the
background a little bit you don't even
see them entirely and of course none of
these paradigms are entirely wrong about
everything it's partly their logic that
sustains them but of course then the
logic gets broadened perhaps beyond what
it should so so the work of engineering
paradigms that take seriously the
complexity of the social world and what
we do with that knowledge is hard work
and but it's it's
like Yale work and it's fixed politics
and economics work right it's your work
as well as mine social movements I think
have had also a very big impact
they just haven't exactly had the full
impact one might some my desire in these
particular areas but I'll mention three
places where I would argue they've had a
substantial impact the treatment of
women public health and civil rights so
the the civil rights story is the most
familiar and in some ways you could say
I'm I'm trying to make a plea that in
addition to scientists we think of these
problems as suitable to MLK to rhetoric
to mobilization to a sense that there's
an inspiration around these issues and
that's why in a way some of what it
takes is to sound scary but also
optimistic enough to mobilize people to
make them feel like they can make a
difference but that's work for others to
do not for judges to do on public health
I would say many of the public health
issues I've worked on in my career like
food safety tobacco I can't imagine the
scientists getting to do their work and
the lawyers getting to enact legislation
without the concern of moms across
parties were freaked out about how this
particular thing that their kids ate is
gonna make their kids have a long term
disability like forever there's nothing
like a roomful of moms or dads parents
who are freaked out about that and it's
it's moving in a way but it tells you a
story of why it is that when we send the
food when the President signed the food
modernization act and we worked on it
you know a team of people on it you
could look out on at the Rose Garden and
see Republican and Democratic senators
from red and you know green and purple
and blue states all co-sponsoring that
and being there for the ceremony so I'm
sounding optimistic again and I don't
mean to sound overly optimistic but I
feel like there's a reason to feel like
there's still a logic that we can
leverage to end up in a better place you
had a question
in times of emergency you need to and
the question the problem I see today is
my own fear of people and religious
climate change with a short-term
interest as you said before to
proliferate or fertility of economics is
to neglect it the long term it was
obvious that mr. solving because the way
democracy structured was myopia doesn't
seem we're getting the direct and I'm
from China so I see in China that's
really leading the fight right now it's
a non democratic process that's creating
a lot of results earlier you mentioned
that in the US there's no federal law
which requires the President to use
nuclear weapons approval do you think if
climate change is a state of emergency
wouldn't it make sense for a similar
statute regulations with
so being from California it's hard for
me not to think of the mix of
circumstances and effects associated
with climate change as being anything
other than an emergency and so that
doesn't change necessarily the way I
think about the cases when they come to
me it's a question of applying the law
and trying to be do right by what has
been enacted there but as a scholar I
would say it's hard for me to think that
the world should should treat this as
anything other than an emergency but of
course that then raises the next part of
your question which is what what should
we expect from a responsible thoughtful
ethical government in an emergency and I
would actually distinguish between three
different modes of action there are many
others but just three to illustrate some
distinctions one would be a very
participatory democracy approach which
would argue that the public is a
constraint for a reason that we get as
close as possible to the public itself
being brought along to see something as
an emergency and that particularly if
you don't have to make a snap judgment
the responsibility you have is to
actually bring the public along and so
one example that I could give from
American history where that approach was
largely followed not entirely well maybe
not quite but but Advent let me let me
illustrate it this way at various points
presidents might have said I need to do
this but I but I'd best do it with the
support of the general public so there
were aspects of how Franklin Roosevelt
handled the lead-up to World War two
that have elements of this not purely
but have elements of I need to get the
public to understand why this is
important why it's in their interest
that we do this at the other extreme I
would suggest a position that is about
the emergency being so compelling that
it's not worth delaying to engage the
public and I guess you know here there's
some room for a discussion about how the
world works and
should work but my own view is probably
shaped by my experiences in American
which is to be distrustful of any
severing of that link and I would say
the courts are a good example where that
link is sort of maintained in between we
do things that are counter majoritarian
in the court the legislature wants to do
something and sometimes we say no that
is our job sometimes to protect people
by enforcing the Constitution but that's
it that's it something that requires
caution and care right and I would I
would note that for better and not
better in our country our courts have an
electoral check sometimes and that works
in different ways but at least in
California their retention elections
every 12 years so that brings me to the
intermediate position which is perhaps
someone that I would favor the most and
that is a leader saying I'm a leader I'm
not just a walking talking referendum
for public opinion I'm supposed to lead
I'm supposed to illustrate where I
believe Society should come and then I'm
supposed to try to bring you along and
persuade you but as a Marty Stein would
say I have the constraints of persuading
you because without that you rightly
will fear me and you should because
there may not be a limit to what I'm
going to do to you and I think that's a
tension because I don't think that
always works so I'm I'm looking for
further dialogue and deliberation but at
least where I'm coming from it's very
important to maintain that link to how
are you in a persuade the public
[Applause]
[Music]
you